IT'S TIME TO PLAY
FLIGHT RISKS.
(APPLAUSE)
NOW WE ALL HATE FLYING BUT IT
HAS A LOT OF IT HAS TO DO WITH
OTHER PASSENGERS.
FORMER FLIGHT ATTENDANT SEAN
CATHLEEN DECIDED TO ISSUE
HER OWN BRAND OF VIGILANTE
JUSTICE BY CREATING A
FACEBOOK PAGE CALLED
PASSENGER SHAMING, WHICH IS
THANKFULLY WHAT IT SOUNDS
LIKE.
PHOTOS SUBMITTED FROM
FACEBOOK USERS OF THE MOST
INAPPROPRIATE AIRLINE
TRAVELERS BEHAVIOR.
SO I'M GONNA SHOW YOU A PICTURE
FOR THE PASSENGER SHAMING
FACEBOOK, AND FOR 250 POINTS, I
WANT YOU TO TELL ME THE REASON
THEY'RE FLYING.
OKAY.
FIRST ONE, LOOK AT THIS
WALKING 4LOKO POSTER.
(LAUGHTER)
IS THAT McCONNEGHEY?
JERRY MINOR.
>> YEAH, HE DON'T KNOW EITHER.
HE WOKE UP LIKE THIS.
YOLO.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
APRIL.
>> HE'S CLEARLY TRAVELING TO
FLORIDA FOR A MEETING OF HIS
INTERNATIONAL METH CARTEL.
>> CHRIS: YEAH, POINTS.
(APPLAUSE)
THAT'S DEFINETLY HAPPENING.
POINTS FOR THAT, NEXT ONE.
WHO HASN'T SAT IN A FLIGHT NEXT
TO THIS PERSON.
>> OH MY GOODNESS.
>> CHRIS: OH BROTHER.
MOSHE.
>> TO EAT ANOTHER THAI CHILD
BRIDE.
>> CHRIS: YEAH.
(APPLAUSE)
POINTS.
>> DID HE PUT A PILLOWCASE
OVER HIS HEAD TO COVER HIS
EYES, I GUESS?
I MEAN -- HE'S UNCOVERED THE
PART YOU DON'T WANT TO SEE.
>> HE'S A MEMBER OF THE
KU KLUX CLOWN.
>> CHRIS: YEAH.
(APPLAUSE)
APRIL?
>> HE IS TRAVELING BECAUSE
HE'S GOT TO MAKE IT TO A JOB
INTERVIEW AS SOUS CHEF AT GUY
FIERI'S NEW RESTAURANT.
(APPLAUSE)
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
>> HE'S A PROFESSIONAL.
>> CHRIS: ALL RIGHT, NEXT ONE.
THIS ONE, BECAUSE YOU CAN
NEVER BE TOO SAFE.
NEVER-- BE TOO SAFE.
>> APRIL.
>> HE'S ONLY FLYING BECAUSE
HE HAS YET TO TURN INTO A
BUTTERFLY.
>> YES.
POINTS.
>> HE'S BEING PRACTICAL.
>> CHRIS: JERRY.
>> YEAH, THEY MAKE SHAQ BUY A
PARTICULAR FOR HIS CONDOM.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
NEXT ONE, HOW ABOUT THIS
FIRST CLASS TRAVELER.
APRIL.
>> YOU GUYS, HE JUST WANTS
TO MAKE IT HOME IN TIME TO
OD WITH HIS FAMILY FOR
CHRISTMAS.
THAT'S SAD.
>> FUNNY.
>>CHRIS: POINTS. YEP.
AND FINALLY, THIS PERSON.
JERRY?
>> HE'S GOING TO TAKE OFFICE
AS THE MAYOR OF FUNKY TOWN.
>> CHRIS: YES, POINTS.